Justin Timberlake busy in front yeah
Justin his turn the last two shows of
his 20/20 experience world tour into a
feature-length film and our camera
Mathis ain't caught up with JT let me
see Netflix and chill has got a new
meaning it's gonna be now Timberlake and
chill right come on how does that feel
that was the zinger
you've heard the internet slang now the
man who brought sexy back is putting on
a suit and tie for Netflix the concert
film Justin Timberlake and the Tennessee
kids premiered last night the movie
follows JT and his 25 member band at
their final tour date on his 20/20
experience world to work you know the
tour that brought us songs like how
excited are you for your fans to will
have to see this one I wasn't sure how I
was going to feel about it there's not a
character yeah that I can sort of hide
behind her talk about it like oh that's
me
Justin asked oscar-winning director
Jonathan Demi to document every moment
on stage and off tonight
look to your right look to your left
that's what this show is for who else
would you like to collaborate with I
don't know I want to do let's let's make
them let's make another movie together
yeah Justin and Jason Segel I want you
guys to do a movie together with me and
Jason call us we're gonna make a movie
together